well it's very very sad I mean he was a
superb public servant and I worked with
him five years when and the cabinet he
was brilliant so getting his head around
very complicated problems in sort of
brokering agreements between ministers
who were implacably opposed and I think
what was remarkable as he worked for Lib
Dem conservative labor ministers and
none of us had the faintest idea what
his politics were I mean he was just the
perfect civil servant I'm just very very
good at his job and it's rather trudging
he's died at such a young age and yeah
well quite exactly and I think perhaps
the the thing that nobody could tell his
politics that's one the highest
conference you could pay a civil servant
and I'm keen to talk to you about Breck
said and this morning we've had a letter
from 50 business leaders demanding a
second referendum how likely do you
think it is the second referendum will
happen 50 percent more or less I think
probably a bit less than that but it's
certainly one of the options that is
available and it's the right option I
think we may well get into a position
where the Teresa mayor comes back with
the deal we've had a sketch this morning
from early reputable journalists giving
us some indication about what might be
involved I think it's rather unlikely
that that will command a majority in the
House of Commons there's certainly no
majority of no deal which would be a
complete disaster and going back to the
country and saying well this is the best
I can do do you want that or do you want
to stay in the European Union only thing
that would be a fair and democratic way
of dealing with it and there is a
growing support I think reflected in the
March a few years ago the statements of
these business leaders and others so I'm
interested if you think that the
likelihood of a second referendum
happening is under 50% what happens to
the Lib Dems if the UK does leave the EU
next year are you gonna campaign to
rejoin well we obviously have to take
stock of where we then are and we would
certainly want us to remain very close
to the European Union because it's so
much part of our life potentially to
rejoin even if it might mean rejoining
of the colony would be very very
difficult because the so-called article
51 process which creates significant
hurdles
no it will obviously have to if this
happens we hope it won't and we think
there's a good chance it won't but but
if this happens we'll obviously need to
sit down and think about the long-term
future which does link us to the
European Union where the rejoining or
whatever is it is first to think through
but we are a European country and we are
very closely linked through trade
through movements of people in many
other ways and it will be foolish to
unscramble all of that very damaging to
the country and nobody has yet come up
with any kind of deal which is remotely
comparable to the deal we already have
you've said before that when brexit is
resolved you'll step down as leader
so what timetable is that I mean you're
talking about next unit well what I've
said is that I'm trying to be
professional about it and create an
orderly succession and I've said there
are certain jobs for me to do and and
one of them is to see is through the
Rexie presence we've got local
government election this year then maybe
there the election there are certain
reforms I'm going to put through the
party which will take some months when
all of that's completed then I'm ready
to help the the next generation move on
but I'm not sitting at time under but it
sounds from what you're saying it could
be next year is that right it's quite
possible but not being definite about
time because I'm working to specific
tasks rather than setting an artificial
deadline would you be tempted by job at
Facebook no I have work to the big
multinational campaign if I enjoyed
doing it but it was very good experience
but no I I'm not looking for a job I
actually enjoy writing books and I enjoy
my politics I love being a constituency
MP and these are things I'll be
continuing to do are we surprised when
cynic like announced that he was to an
any place but not completely I mean he's
young man by political standards God is
very capable and he's getting experience
in a global business and why not and now
this week and Philip Dunn's announced
that you were cutting staff at your
London HQ it's been a difficult period
has meant for the Liberal Democrats and
disappointing election results
you haven't had a breakthrough in the
polls that you may have
I hoped for with your opposition to
brexit and why did you cut those staff
members and what does it say about the
state of your party well I'm very sorry
for the people who will be affected by
that but it isn't the problem unique to
us I think all political parties are
currently having the struggle with
finance because you know we've been
under a lot of financial pressure we've
had two general elections two
referendums and what you know like any
other organizations we've got to live
within our means so I do feel for the
people who are now worried about that
position but it's it's something we have
to do as far as the future of the Lib
Dems concerned I'm optimistic I mean we
haven't had a test of electoral opinion
but where there has been at local level
I mean every Thursday the local
by-election we're doing extremely well
they're outperforming labour and
conservatives at that level our opinion
polls ratings as you say are not great
I'd like them to be much higher but
there are several points up on on the
position I inherited our membership is
very strong and we have a key leadership
role in all of this campaign against
brexit so I'm very happy with where
we're heading suppose